[Silly accent] Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to
Sonic Suggests
The game where you...
...I-I honestly have no id- Oh...
OH...
[Electronic music]
[Markiplier giggles]
[Laughing] Oh no...
Oh-
Eggman: Sonic. How I hate him...
Eggman: BURN!
[Music distorts and fades]
[Zapping sound]
[Funky victory music]
[Music fades out]
[Ambient noise/music]
Oh-- Oh no, am I--
[Mark laughs]
I'm falling! We're falling!!
WE'RE STILL FALLING--
Oh.
I guess we're okay then.
Oh, is this just-- Wait, how do I--
Do I have any camera controls? Do I- Is there just no point to having...? I don't have any camera controls do I?
In-game narration: Grove Street, Home. At least it was till I fucked everything up.
Excuse me? [Laughs]
[Slightly distressed] I have no idea what's happening.
Can I actually hit thi-- Oh, okay...
Can I hit this... thing?
All right, so that works.
How do I turn the camera? How do I in any way shape or form, turn the--
Oh, I don't. Okay, I don't.
Ah...
Oh...
Oh...!
Oh, it's beautiful!
Oh, It's so cinematic!
Oh it's so beautiful!
Somehow I doubt that. Somehow, I really doubt...
This is a Hideo Kojima game. I really-- [Chuckles]
A sequel to Sonic Forces.
Ah.
[Upbeat action music starts playing]
Okay, I get it.
Tails: Sonic, help me!
Oh, all right, sure. Oh no...
[Laughs in disbelief] What--
Oh, hey, let go of Tails there.
What's weird about this game Is it seems to be taking itself seriously?
But not? But-- I mean, it's like... It's not taking yourself seriously
but also it's like, better made than just a Garbo Sonic game?
Whoo combo.
Hello.
So-- Tails, can you get that one for me? Thank you.
[Laughs] I guess we'll uh-- Oh...
Tails, thank you for getting in my way there.
Tails get out of my WAY! Tails! This is my special-- TAILS! This is my special mo--
There we go-- TAILS.
God, damn it. This son of a-
Alright, whatever, we're just gonna keep going this way.
Tails wants to ruin my day and I can't experience the fun and joy that I WANTED to get out of this game--
Oh my god.
Ah-- Oh, a big one! See, the thing is like I - I honestly have no complaints about the game at this point.
I really don't! I have no complaints, none at all. This is actually pretty well made!
The music's a little grating but...
Knuckles: Sonic is alive!
Am I? Knuckles, is that you??
I don't exactly know what happened to me, but I'm gonna assume that--
All right. Anyway, see ya. See you around the bend, buddy.
I WAS-- oookay. All right.
You can't just-- What is that spin move? Oh, it's doing-- Knuckles come back-- Knuckles, why are you a dog?
Knuckles, why are you walking on all four-- Wait, did you get-- Wha? Whooho... Oh, you're better now... I guess.
Ooohh...
Okay...
Oh no...
All right, well, come along... Come along now.
Whoa... What happens if I do this?
OHH!!!
Oh, it's death, alriiight. I'm so confused. [Laughs]
Okay, so don't touch the mega spr- spring, go to the boss.
ALL RIGHT BOSS, I'm coming for you wherever you are, it's gonna be you and me...
You and me facing off to the end of days-- Is that you Eggman?!
HUH EGG BOY?! Oh get back here...
Eggman: (No way, I can't believe this!)
Yeah, I can't believe it either. How did that plan of yours not work. How - how am I supposed to-- Oh!
Eggman: ALL SYSTEMS FULL POWER!
Mark: ...Wow... Okay.
Eggnan: Hmph! Not bad!
Mark: Oh--
Eggman: Hmph! THIS IS ONLY THE BEGINNING!!!
[Mark giggles]
Alright okay alright Eggman.
Can I - can I please catch up to you Eggman??
Eggboy!
Eggman: Don't get too excited boys!
I wasn't getting too excited to be perfectly honest
in fact, I was getting kind of concerned about the...
The whole reality of this existence because it was kind of messed up even before!
Even before you tripped me with the - the power
[Eggman's machine explodes]
[Comedically over-dramatic music]
[Laughing] Oh my god!
[Mark makes noises halfway between laughter and cries of distress]
Oh, kick him while he's down, okay. Oh, good job. Good job, everybody. Good job.
Oooohhh...
So he's dead and you just throw him into the river?
[Bubbly sound effect as Eggman sinks]
Oh no...
[Music fades out]
[Funky victory music from opening]
[Loud pop]
Oh?
"When everything you know has come and gone."
[Distorted theme of Infinite - Sonic Forces plays]
(You are at your lowest, I am rising higher)
"Only scars remain of who I was."
(What we’ll find in ashes, you lose in the fire)
"When there’s no one left to carry on."
(This is an illusion, open up your eyes and...)
"This pain"
(Persists)
"I can't"
(Resist)
"But that’s what it takes to be Infinite."
[Sound of being zapped out of existence]
[Music stops]
[Windows notification sound]
Oh, Java update!
[Mark wheezes]
[Laughing] Wait, wait was that in the game? The Java update, was that in the game?!
I think that was-- I think they programmed that in because it faded out at the exact same time.
I'm positive that was...
[Mark laughs]
I'm positive that was part of it
Okay, all right, wow that was...
That was a thing of beauty. That was honestly a thing of beauty. That was...
Wow, that was a goddamn delight.
[Noise of relief]
[Sigh]
No, you have to remember this. For the end of your days
you have to remember that. You have to live with the knowledge that you...
Saw that.
[Previous rock music returns, just as loudly and suddenly]
[Music begins to 'glitch']